[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serin gute Abend nie war eine
Fußball-WM politischer darum auch wieder
Thema bei uns neben all dem sportlichen
das Christin Otto später wieder im Blick
hat ein toller Einstieg für die
Engländer guten Abend wir schauen uns
die Themen im Überblick an
Statement für Menschenrechte in Katar
unerwünscht die FIFA verbietet die One
Love Armbinde der DFB und andere
Europäer sind empört geben aber nach
Solidarität für Protestbewegung Irans
Nationalmannschaft schweigt bei der
Nationalhymne während das Regime zu
Hause gewaltsam gegen Demonstranten
vorgeht
und schweres Erdbeben auf Java auf der
indonesischen Insel sprechen die
Behörden von mehr als 160 Toten hunderte
weitere wurden verletzt
[Musik]
die Geschichte der noch sehr jungen
Fußball-WM ist schon reich an Skandalen
und Vorwürfen der jüngste eklatan heute
Mittag mehrere europäische Fußballteams
darunter Deutschland beugen sich dem
Druck der FIFA die hatte Sanktionen
angedroht für den Fall dass die Teams
wie angekündigt mit sogenannter One Love
Kapitänsbinde ein Zeichen setzen für
Diversität jetzt ist die Aufregung groß
und der DFB spricht von
Machtdemonstration und Zensur Heiko
Klasen
es herrscht Rede es herrscht
Erklärungsbedarf beim DFB noch bis
gestern war man sich absolut sicher dass
Manuel Neuer mit der One Love
Kapitänsbinde auch gegen Japan auflaufen
würde das hat die FIFA heute endgültig
verboten die FIFA hat heute eine Aussage
für Diversität und Menschenrechte
untersagt das sind Werte zu denen sie
sich in ihren eigenen Statuten
verpflichtet
das ist aus unserer Sicht mehr als
frustrierend und auch ein beispielloser
Vorgang in der WM Geschichte wie ich
finde eine Entscheidung der FIFA die in
ihrer Wirkung weit über die Welt des
Sports hinausgeht die in Deutschland
auch für den Sport zuständige
Innenministerin erreichte die
Nachrichten Ankara nennt sie Feser ist
mehr als empört dass das jetzt von der
FIFA so untersagt wird finde ich nicht
in Ordnung finde ich sehr befremdlich
und finde es auch alles andere als gut
dass es jetzt wieder einmal auf den
Rücken der Sportler ausgetragen wird die
FIFA hat nämlich für den Fall einer
Zuwiderhandlung mit sportlichen
Konsequenzen gedroht das hätten
persönliche Strafen also konkret eine
gelbe Karte für Manuel Neuer oder auch
Punkt Abzüge sein können den Vorwurf der
DFB sei daraufhin vor der FIFA
eingeknickt weiß der Präsident aber
zurück gerade wie als DFB müssen uns dem
Vorwurf nicht aussetzen dass wir
eingeknickt sind sie erinnern sich vor
einer Woche als ich noch verkündet habe
dass wir keine Nominierung für Gianni
Infantino für seine Wiederwahl zum
Ministerpräsidenten vornehmen werden und
ich glaube das war doch ein deutliches
Signal auch Richtung FIFA dass wir nicht
bereit sind bestimmte Dinge die seitens
der FIFA kommen mitzutragen neben den
Deutschen wollten noch weitere 7
europäische WM Teilnehmer mit der one
love-kapitänsbinde auflaufen unter
anderem auch die Engländer die nur
wenige Stunden vor ihrem Spiel gegen den
Iran vom fifa-verbot erfahren hatten
Harry Kane lief dann gezwungenermaßen
mit einer offiziellen FIFA auf
es fühlt sich schon stark nach Zensur an
und ähm man kann es natürlich die Binde
nehmen ja aber die Werte für die wir
stehen die werden wir haben und die
werden auch immer wieder zum Ausdruck
bringen ganz in diesem Sinne haben DFB
und deutsche Mannschaft Aktionen abseits
des offiziellen fifa-programms
angekündigt
ist für uns in Kata golinity FIFA
Entscheidungen zur Kapitänsbinde die
schlägt in Deutschland hohe Wellen
verfestigt den Eindruck einer
merkwürdigen WM wie wird das eben Cutter
gesehen und diskutiert
also offizielle Reaktionen hat es hier
nicht gegeben ich rechne auch nicht
damit dass es die geben wird man wird
nicht in einen offenen
Konfrontationskurs gehen wollen einzig
in den arabischsprachigen sozialen
Medien da wird natürlich Katha jetzt
wieder gefeiert für einen erneuten Sieg
einen heldenhaften Sieg so heißt es
gegen westlichen Zwang jetzt ist
Homophobie im arabischen Raum nichts
Neues aber diese Maßnahme heute die
reiht sich ein in eine sehr koordiniert
wirkende Serie von Maßnahmen dieses Jahr
gegen LGBT Menschen hier in den Golf
Monarchien z.B das konfiszieren von
Spielzeugen in Regenbogenfarben in Saudi
Arabien oder im Oman aber auch zum
Beispiel Maßnahmen im vergleichsweise
Liberalen in den vergleichsweise
Liberalen Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten wo plötzlich Schulbücher dieses
Jahr überarbeitet werden und ein Verbot
erlassen wird über Homosexuelle
Homosexualität zu sprechen aber auch die
Aufforderung des Golf kooperationsrates
zum Beispiel an den live
Streaming-Dienst Netflix Homosexuelle
Inhalte für den Raum hier zu sperren und
das Ganze wirkt sehr koordiniert und es
scheint auch ja ein populistisches
Gefühl hier zu bedienen denn in
Gesellschaften in denen keine
politischen Forderungen gestellt werden
können kommt natürlich diese lgbt-frage
genau richtig um die Konservativen
Elemente hier in den Gesellschaften
zufriedenzustellen
vielen Dank nach Katha die große Bühne
der Fußball-WM nutzten die iranischen
Nationalspieler für stummen Protest als
Zeichen der Solidarität mit der
Freiheitsbewegung in ihrer Heimat sangen
sie vor ihrer heutigen Partie die
Nationalhymne nicht mit im Iran wird
weiter gegen das Regime demonstriert
über die anhaltenden Proteste dort und
das Signal dass Irans Fußballer aus Kata
sendeten lügwald
beim WM-Spiel in Katar blieben sie heute
stumm
irans-nationalspieler verweigerten das
Absingen der Hymne der Islamischen
Republik deutlicher Protest gegen das
unterdrückungsregime zu Hause auf den
Rängen Tränen der Solidarität und mehr
Proteste Frauen ohne Kopftuch mit der
alten persischen Nationalflagge vor dem
Stadion Festnahmen obwohl die Flagge in
der Hosentasche verschwindet
das ist die wirkliche persische Flagge
nicht die hier das ist die islamische
auch am Abend finden sich protestierende
Fans Freiheit für Iran rufen Sie in Doha
unterdessen erlebten Menschen in
mehreren kurdisch bewohnten Städten im
Nordwesten Irans heute brutalste Gewalt
der Staates
das Regime geht mit Gewehrsalven gegen
Protestierende in Javan Ruth in Piranha
in machabat vor mal gezielt mal wahllos
abgefeuert auf unbewaffnete
Menschenrechtsgruppen sprechen von
mehreren Toten vielen Verletzten genaue
Zahlen gibt es bislang nicht
inzwischen sind schwer bewaffnete
Militäreinheiten der Revolutionswächter
eingetroffen man werde jetzt heißt es
verstärkt gegen die separatistischen
Terrorgruppen Vorgehen bereits gestern
hatte Iran Ziele jenseits der Grenze im
kurdischen Nordirak angegriffen
mindestens ein Mensch kam dabei ums
Leben in Teheran hieß es dazu heute nur
Iran hat das Recht seine Grenzen und die
Sicherheit seiner Bürger zu schützen und
Bedrohungen aus dem Ausland abzuwehren
in Mahabad wurden unterdessen die Opfer
der Polizeigewalt beigesetzt
jetzt in die Ukraine jeden Tag
Raketenbeschuss vor allem auf die
Infrastruktur bei winterlichen
Temperaturen sind jetzt schon 10
Millionen Menschen ohne Strom die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation spricht von
der größten Attacke auf die
Gesundheitsversorgung auf europäischen
Boden seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg davon
betroffen hunderte Krankenhäuser und die
aller Schwächsten der Gesellschaft außer
deshalb berichtet Hannah Hebestreit
sie leiden besonders unter dem Krieg und
den russischen Attacken auf die zivile
Infrastruktur im Kinderkrankenhaus für
die ganze Region und deshalb kämpfen die
Ärzte um das Überleben ihrer kleinen
Patienten in den Fluren ist es dämmrich
sobald der Strom ausfällt hängt die
Energieversorgung für diese Abteilung
mit ihren 170 Betten an diesem Generator
das Benzin für dieses Gerät reicht für 7
Tage wenn wir ihn länger brauchen müssen
wir uns auf die Suche nach mehr
Treibstoff machen
der Generator verbraucht Geld dass sie
dringender für Medikamente für ihre
Patienten brauchen die Ukraine hat
Unterstützung bitter nötig nach Angaben
der Weltgesundheitsorganisation ist
Russlands Angriff die größte Bedrohung
für die Gesundheitsversorgung innerhalb
Europas seit dem letzten Weltkrieg
dramatisch ist die die Energieversorgung
zum Teil auch die die mangelnde
Medikamentenversorgung auch natürlich
das jetzt Spezialisten teilweise nicht
mehr verfügbar sind also insgesamt ist
der einbrechende Winter eine massive
Herausforderung für das Gesundheitswesen
hier in der Ukraine die Ärzte geben sich
alle Mühe doch ist doch ihre Kraft nicht
unendlich
sie haben außergewöhnlichen Psychos
Stress denn wenn Sie nach Hause kommen
ist es dort dunkel wegen des
Stromausfalls und Sie können sich nicht
erholen aber wir wissen warum wir die
Ukraine nicht verlassen
700 Gesundheitseinrichtungen wurden im
ganzen Land schon zerstört wenn in
Odessa Luftalarm ist bringen Sie die
kleinen Patienten in diesem Keller in
Sicherheit
die Terminals für Flüssiggas Tanker
werden deutlich teurer als veranschlagt
zusätzlich könnten rund 3,5 Milliarden
Euro fällig werden hieß es aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium für 2022 waren
bisher knapp drei Milliarden Euro
veranschlagt worden ein Grund bei der
eiligen Genehmigung wurden viele Kosten
zunächst geschätzt und erst später genau
bestimmt das erste Terminal soll im
Dezember in Wilhelmshaven ans Netz gehen
jetzt zum Streit um das Bürgergeld das
Jahr Hartz IV ablösen soll diese Woche
entscheidet sich ob es wie geplant ab
Januar kommt oder nicht die Union
kritisiert dass es zu wenig Anreize zum
Arbeiten gäbe und hatte es im Bundesrat
blockiert darum soll der
Vermittlungsausschuss am Mittwoch die
Lösung bringen ob es inzwischen Zeichen
der Annäherung gibt dazu Lars Bohnsack
zwei Tage noch dann wird sich hier im
Bundesrat zeigen ob ein Kompromiss noch
möglich ist aus der Union kommen
unterschiedliche Signale Bayerns
Ministerpräsident stellt für seine
Zustimmung zwei Bedingungen dass das
sogenannte Schonvermögen ist derzeit bei
150.000 € sich insgesamt addiert
deutlichst reduziert wird nahezu
halbiert wird das wäre eine wichtige
Voraussetzung des zweites für uns ganz
entscheidend dass die Sanktionen wieder
in Kraft treten aufhorchen lässt heute
die FDP ihr Generalsekretär schwenkt auf
die Linie der Union einfordert weiter
volle Sanktionen auch in den ersten
sechs Monaten und kritisiert die eigenen
Koalitionspartner nicht nur die Union
muss sich bewegen sondern auch gerade
beim Thema Sanktion vertrauenszeit hier
müssen sich auch SPD und Grüne bewegend
bewegen und ich bin sogar der Meinung
dass wir hier so weit gehen können um
auch diese vertrauenszeit ja auch fallen
lassen können der Vorstoß ist in der am
offenbar nicht abgesprochen SPD und
Grüne sind sauer beim Bürgergeld würde
ich weiterhin dazu raten nicht Dinge auf
der öffentlichen Bühne auszubreiten sich
schon gar nicht aufzuplustern ich
vertrauenszeit gilt für uns auch für
Verhandlungen und diese Verhandlungen
finden Vermittlungsausschuss statt die
Linke waren die Ampel vor
Zugeständnissen an die Union wir
beteiligen uns nicht an diesem
Wettbewerb der Schäbigkeit wir
kritisieren den Gesetzentwurf der Ampel
weil er eben nicht dazu führt Leute aus
der Armut zu holen und wir kritisieren
die Union die das auch noch blockieren
will und den Menschen nicht mal klein zu
Verbesserungen gönnt sollte im
Vermittlungsausschuss kein Kompromiss
gefunden werden können auch die
Regelsätze der Hartz IV Empfänger nicht
zum ersten Januar erhöht werden
jetzt nach Indonesien dort hat einen
Erdbeben der Stärke 5,6 die Insel Java
erschüttert mehr als 160 Tote wurden
bislang geborgen hunderte wurden
verletzt das Epizentrum lag in der
Provinz West Java nahe der Stadt
chiangur hier gab es auch die größten
Schäden der gut 100 Kilometer vom
Epizentrum entfernten Hauptstadt Jakarta
war das Beben auch deutlich zu spüren
Normen Odenthal berichtet die
Opferzahlen steigen weiter und weiter
egal was Sie versuchen zu oft geht der
Kampf verloren viele Verletzte sind noch
in Lebensgefahr und viele Menschen
werden noch vermisst überall Angst
Entsetzen Ungewissheit
der district-chef berichtet von
dutzenden Toten hunderten Verletzten
aber es ist sehr schwierig für die
Rettungskräfte sagt er denn die Zahlen
müssen ständig korrigiert werden es sind
einfach zu viele
draußen vor dem Krankenhaus von chiangua
das provisorische Lazarett platzt aus
allen Nähten
Knochenbrüche Quetschungen viele wurden
unter den Trümmern ihrer Häuser geborgen
aber viele stecken dort wohl auch noch
fest
mehrere Erdstöße jeweils nur wenige
Sekunden lang haben die Region
erschüttert das war genug das war zu
viel es ist nicht leicht einen Überblick
zu bekommen von den Zerstörungen den
Schäden den Opfern
es gibt Gebiete die wir leider noch
immer nicht erreichen konnten die Straße
nach mangun ist nach einem Erdrutsch
komplett blockiert das heißt keiner
kommt rein oder raus
es ist also auch ein Kampf gegen die
Zeit sie müssen Opfer Bergen verletzte
retten sie müssen Überlebende in
Sicherheit bringen denn immer wieder
bebt die Erde aufs Neue es sind bange
Stunden auf Java
ein wichtiger Tag heute für die jüdische
Gemeinschaft in Hannover wurden fünf
orthodoxe Rabbiner feierlich eingesetzt
in Niedersachsen das erste Mal seit Ende
des Zweiten Weltkriegs mit dabei war
auch Bundespräsident Steinmeier mit
Blick auf immer mehr antisemitische
Straftaten meinte er zu Wachsamkeit in
Deutschland zeigen sich Antisemitismus
wieder viel unverhohlener und offener so
der Bundespräsident
immer ein paar Zehner Münzgeld dabei
haben das war früher als es noch keine
Handys gab absolut wichtig man musste ja
telefonieren können wenn man unterwegs
war nämlich von solchen Telefonhäuschen
aus die ist quasi überall gab über die
Jahrzehnte wurde denen ein neuer Look
verpasst jetzt aber ist endgültig
Schluss jedenfalls mit den
Münzfernsprechern Ralf Goldmann über
einen Abschied der manche wehmütig macht
einfach mal sagen dass man sie liebt das
geht hier jetzt nur noch mit einer
Telefonkarte denn die Tage der 12.000
übrig gebliebenen öffentlichen
Münzfernsprecher sind gezählt sie nehmen
seit heute keine Münzen mehr an
[Musik]
man hat viel erlebt mit Telefonzellen ja
Geschichten Gerüche alles mögliche und
die Jüngeren gucken einen an und fragen
einen äh wieso ist da ein Hörer in einer
Schnur und wo kann man hier snipen also
insofern das ist ein bisschen
unterschiedlich aber ein bisschen ja
auch dabei im Januar ist ganz Schluss
auch Telefonkarten funktionieren dann
nicht mehr die letzte gelbe Zelle wurde
schon vor drei Jahren abgebaut irgendwie
waren sie überall aber nie da wo man sie
brauchte unverzichtbar aber oft kaputt
Fluch und Segen zugleich
naja damals ist man das schon
hingegangen und hat dann mal telefoniert
wenn die Eltern nicht mithören sollten
aber das ist schon echt verdammt lange
her jetzt sind sie nur noch Stromfresser
und die junge Generation rätselt über
Sinn und Zweck dieser komischen Geräte
als ich 15 bin
was geht ja ja ich höre auch immer so
Geschichten dass sie sich früher so
verabredet haben ja du bist an der
Telefonzelle ich bin hier und dann
machen wir das aber ich hätte die Zeit
gerne erlebt aber leider nicht die alten
gelben Zellen haben sich längst Sammler
unter die Nägel gerissen bis 2025 sollen
auch die neueren Modelle aus den
Stadtbildern verschwunden sein an
manchen Orten ist das vielleicht auch
ganz gut so
schlimm war auch mal wenn man Schlange
stehen musste
aber der WM-Ball Rollen das gab ein
Superstart für die Engländer so hoch wie
nie zuvor Spielfreude und schöne Treffer
der EM Finalist aus England hat ein
klares Achtungszeichen gesetzt und seine
Titel Ambitionen gleich zum Auftakt
untermauert 6:2 gegen Außenseiter Iran
Selbstbewusstsein gestärkt die Engländer
mit hoher Qualität
es war ein Fußballspektakel auf allen
Ebenen 27 Minuten Rekord Nachspielzeit
größtenteils verletzungsbedingt und 8
Tore überlegene Auftakt des Teams von
Dortmunder duellingham und der köpft zur
Führung 1:035 Minute wie beflügel
zaubert England noch vor der Pause
weiter besonders sehenswert von Kapitän
Harry Kane vorgelegt das 3:0 durch Rahim
Stirling England im Flow Iran mit nur
20% Ball besitzt und auch nach der Pause
dominiert das Team der Three Lions Sager
mit dem 4:0 dann zwar ein kleiner
Stolperer Iran gelingt der Anschluss
wunderschön durch darini 65 minute doch
für England keinen Rückschlag rashford
erhöht zum 5 zu 1 das Spiel fast zu Ende
aber England noch nicht fertig mit dem 6
in der 90 Minute in der Nachspielzeit
trifft Iran dann doch noch mal per faul
Elfmeter Endergebnis sechs zu zwei
nicht ganz so souverän aber auch
erfolgreich der turnierstaat für die
hoch gehandelten Niederländer Oranien
vor vier Jahren in Russland nicht dabei
tatsächlich etwas schwer setzte sich
aber doch noch gegen Afrika Meister
Senegal mit 2:0 durch
Senegal mit beschwingtem Auftritt in der
ersten Hälfte lassen die Afrikaner nur
diese eine große Chance der Niederlande
zu doch Frankie de Jong zögert viel zu
lang orange auch ansonsten erstmal nicht
konsequent genug Trainer von Karl zur
Pause im stimmungs- kaum Besserung in
der zweiten Hälfte aber dann doch noch
einige Jahre Aktion von De Jong Flanke
auf Kapu das eins zu null 84 minute eine
echte Befreiung und in der Nachspielzeit
liegt nach Schuss von dem Pie der
ehemalige Bremer Klassen sogar noch das
zwei zu null nach die erste Party in
orange kann beginnen
und die deutsche Mannschaft bei der
versucht Bundestrainer haben sie Flick
zwei Tage vor dem endrundeneinstieg
gegen Japan zudem auch
bundesinnenministerinnen sie Fehse
reisen wird das Streit Thema
Kapitänsbinde im Training möglichst fern
zu halten kurz vor dem Auftaktspiel
erhöht der wm-beauftragte die Intensität
Durchsetzungsvermögen ist gefragt gegen
Japan vor allem sollen schnelle Konter
verhindert werden so geht es in den
letzten Einheiten vor dem Duell auch
darum die zuletzt anfällige Defensive zu
stärken da gehört halt konnte
Absicherung bei uns ganz oben dazu weil
wir einfach eine Mannschaft haben die
sehr sehr viel Qualität mit dem Ball hat
und auch er offensiv denkt und Tore
erzielen will und
da hatten wir in Vergangenheit manchmal
ein paar Probleme und das darf uns am
Mittwoch nicht passieren
süle wird wohl nicht hinten rechts
sondern innenverteidigen außerdem muss
Flick entscheiden ob der lange verletzte
Thomas Müller schon fit genug ist für
den Sprung in die Stadt elf
und gleich geht's weiter mit WM live
hier im ZDF USA gegen Wales die dritte
Partie des Tages dann vielen Dank
Christine Schnee und Glatteis Regen
Drohnen heute Nacht das und mehr erklärt
gleich Katja horneffer
etwas früher als sonst in der
Halbzeitpause des Spiels USA Wales
meldet sich Marietta Slomka so gegen
20:45 Uhr mit dem heute journal schön
danke schönen Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt gerade entwickelt sich
ein stürmisches tief hier über dem
westlichen Mittelmeer das bringt auch
kahnböen mit und zieht über die Balearen
und Sardinien bis morgen Mittag weiter
nach Mittelitalien es bringt der Alpen
Südseite kräftige Schneefälle aber so
ganz ungefährlich ist das Wetter auch
bei uns in Deutschland nicht und das
liegt an Nachttemperaturen von maisplus
3 bis -5 Grad es reicht also überall für
Bodenfrost nur das rein Teil ist davon
ausgenommen wenn es dann regnet oder
schneit kann das gefährlich glatt werden
auf den Straßen besonders hier mit
Glatteis Regen von der Nordseeküste bis
etwa nach Thüringen diese gefährlichen
Blätter haben wir es dann auch morgen
über Tag zu tun und zwar zwischen der
Lüneburger Heide und Schleswig-Holstein
das Adria tief bringt Regen und
Schneefälle ungefähr bis zur Donau und
von Westen kommen neue Regenwolken heran
die sich dann am Nachmittag weiter
nordostwärts ausweiten die
Höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen im
Nordosten bei einem bis drei sonst bei 4
bis 10 Grad in den nächsten Tag morgen
geht es wechselhaft weiter es wird aber
deutlich milder am Freitag gegen die
Höchstwerte bei 5 bis 12 Grad wir sehen
uns